deep under the Earth's surface there's a
scorching hot ball of metal and
scientists just discovered that
something very wrong is happening to it
did the Earth's inner core really stop
spinning
what apocalyptic events could this
trigger
and are we doomed to become as lifeless
as Mars
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Earth's core stopped
spinning
if you were to dig straight down into
our planet well you'd shovel through
four distinct layers on your way to the
center
first there's the rocky crust and that's
followed by the hot liquid mantle
2 900 kilometers later you'd reach
Earth's outer core
made up of liquid iron and nickel
combined with the solid iron inner core
the two core layers of our planet are
about the size of Mars
but unlike the red planet they're
scorching hot at 10 000 degrees Celsius
well they're hotter than the surface of
the Sun
and there's also a lot of movement down
there
the motion of molten metal in the outer
core is what's responsible for
generating Earth's magnetic field
without that we wouldn't be able to hold
on to our atmosphere and we'd lose our
protection from dangerous space
radiation and the inner core of our
planet is moving too but new research
suggests that it's slowing down to
rotate more in sync with the rest of the
planet
but slowing down isn't dramatic enough
let's see what happens when both layers
of the core stop moving completely
if only the hot solid inner core inside
the outer core stopped moving well you
wouldn't need to worry about the
apocalypse just yet the slowing down of
the inner core would mostly impact the
speed at which Earth spins
it could slow our rotation down enough
that our days would become longer and
over time this could degrade our
magnetic field
yeah that would be bad news but not
nearly as bad as what would happen if
the syrupy outer core stopped spinning
too
without that layer's rotation well you'd
have to kiss our magnetic field goodbye
and this would put Earth on a course to
end up looking a lot like Mars
4.2 billion years ago Mars could have
been warm enough to have Oceans Where
life might have thrived
but when the red planet's core froze in
place it's once strong magnetic field
weakened
as the Martian magnetic field degraded
its atmosphere was chipped Away by
ferocious solar winds
slamming into the planet at speeds of
several hundred kilometers per second
that's when the planet transformed into
the dry lifeless desert you know today
but back to Earth before it completely
turned into a desert Planet well things
would get a little shaky
if the core was to suddenly stop
rotating
the tectonic plates would violently slam
into each other
it would be a lot like when your bus
driver hits the brakes hard and you go
flying into the other bus riders
this sudden Collision of tectonic plates
would cause massive earthquakes along
the plate boundaries all around the
world
these Quakes would destroy buildings
roads and bridges electricity phone
lines and Water Systems would be severed
ultimately millions of lives would be
lost and millions more people would be
displaced
now as devastating as these earthquakes
would be the damage would just be
getting started
with The Disappearance of our magnetic
field you'd be exposed to dangerous
Cosmic radiation that would bombard the
surface of our planet
these high-energy particles from the Sun
would interact with the abundance of
nitrogen and oxygen in our atmosphere
and this would destroy our protective
ozone layer allowing more UV radiation
to reach the surface
combining these solar rays and UV
radiation would be enormously harmful to
all life on Earth it would damage your
DNA leading to mutations and cancer
and the halting of the core would also
make navigating the globe more difficult
yeah I hope you have a good trail map
for your next camping trip because
compasses would be totally useless
all kinds of migratory animals would
lose their way too
birds flying south would get lost and
freeze to death while sea turtles would
never find their way back to the beaches
that they lay their eggs on
the earthquakes caused by the core
suddenly stopping would have already
done significant damage to the power
infrastructure around the world but the
lack of a magnetic field would continue
disrupting things even more
the solar radiation bombarding the
surface would damage all kinds of
electronic devices and would threaten
our power grids
you would end up losing power more often
maybe even permanently
but in reality you don't have to worry
about a catastrophe like this
this study which implied that the core
has stopped and we're all doomed I was a
little over hyped
scientists didn't even talk about the
outer core no they just meant the inner
core which rotates independently from
the rest of the planet
it doesn't stop or reverse its rotation
it just moves slower and faster like
it's done for the billions of years of
our planet's existence
well good news everyone we're safe on
our big blue Space Rock
at least the planet is still spinning
just imagine what would happen if
Earth's rotation suddenly stopped
well that's a story
for another
what if